[Music]
you are looking at a live picture of an
american eagle our national bird back
here in new york city we have a lot of
national treasures the empire state
building the statue of liberty but what
about natural treasures you probably
don't think of the bald eagle when you
look at that sprawling skyline but
america's national bird is making a big
comeback here in an urban habitat and
it's all by design cbs news's michael
george got a tour with an urban park
ranger who's led the charge to bring the
bald eagle back to new york city from
the brink of extinction
they're majestic fierce
and america's national bird they'll just
glide right over your head sometimes and
it's just such an amazing feeling but
lately bald eagles have been turning up
in the unlikeliest of places
new york city in january bystanders in
central park were awe struck when they
witnessed a bald eagle nicknamed rover
catch a gull in mid-flight eventually
they're going to start to nest here and
live here full time rob mastrianni is a
new york city urban park ranger sergeant
plenty of open space within the hunt
he's been part of a more than 20-year
effort to bring the bald eagles back to
new york the birds used to be plentiful
here but pollution of the city's rivers
and the pesticide ddt brought them to
the brink of extinction what happened
was the eggshells got really thin from
this pesticide the eggs would break and
they weren't reproducing how dire did
things get for the bald eagles here
basically they're almost extinct from
new york state
starting in 2001 the parks department
relocated 20 fledgling eagles from
alaska and wisconsin to manhattan's
inwood hill park that's rob back in 2006
feeding the baby eagles so we would
climb up a ladder it's about 40 50 feet
and there's a little opening on the nest
box where we'd slide the fish in so it
would be like an invisible mom or dad
bringing them food the u.s government
banned the use of ddt in 1972 and in
recent years more funding and resources
have been put toward cleaning up new
york's rivers now the eagles are
thriving the babies rob helped raise
have families and nests of their own and
have migrated to other areas you've been
involved with these eagles for 16 years
now do you develop a personal connection
with them on one of my days off i went
over to visit the nest to have my
binoculars and it was a great feeling to
see
her with her family raising her young so
i kind of felt like a proud parent
foster parent
in the 70s there were believed to be
just two bald eagles left in the entire
state of new york
now there are well over a thousand and
they're no longer considered endangered
they've been spotted in all five
boroughs of new york city you think we
have a shot at seeing some bald eagles i
hope so fingers crossed yeah so if
you're lucky enough on a cold morning
along the hudson river you just may spot
one commuting on an ice floe what are
they hunting for out here they love fish
so they're going for fish that's a
preferred prey and as beautiful as these
birds are to see in the sky that's
nothing compared to seeing one up close
this is montana he's a 12 year old adult
male bald eagle bobby horvath is a
wildlife rehabilitator we rescued him
and unfortunately when we picked him up
he had a broken right wing broken right
leg and he's blind in his right eye but
surviving in a major metropolis presents
its own set of challenges one eagle was
killed by a metro north train and in
february horvath rescued this fledgling
his wings were tangled in a fishing line
she had surgery this week and we won't
know for a couple months if that bird
is going to be fully
recovered the eagles greatest threat is
us
the locations of their nests are
shrouded in secrecy to prevent curious
crowds from gathering close by what can
we do to protect them
appreciate them and enjoy them but just
give them their space we came close to
losing these birds forever but now
they're becoming our neighbors once
again
now this is really a conservation
success story a group of dedicated
people who said we are not going to let
these birds die off 20 years later they
are surviving they are thriving and if
they can make it here in new york city
they can really make it anywhere i've
heard that
that could be asl that could be a song
george michael but but i look at ranger
rob though he's certainly committed from
2006 he's been working with these birds
yeah he has spent so much time
he and a group of others have spent so
much time caring for these birds and so
it's really amazing to see them thrive
and multiply and spread all over the
state it is amazing i hope they uh kill
pigeons don't come at me a pigeon
twitter uh michael george not george
michael
that wasn't
all the time that was an obvious joke
we'll be right back
you got that didn't you george yeah